- C'est important le secondaire
4 c'est l'année la plus
importante du secondaire...
- "Le guide de la famille
parfaite" est une comédie
dramatique sur les hauts
et les bas de la parentalité à
une époque d'hyper performance.
LOUIS MORISSETTE, comédien
et coscénariste du film
- C'est peut-être la chose
la plus autobiograpique
que j'ai faite depuis
le début de ma carrière.
- Il faut closer des dosier.
- Louis Morissette interprète
un père qui a de grandes
ambitions pour sa fille, pour
qu'elle soit presque parfaite.
Inévitablement, il y a
des tensions.
- S'susez, c'mon, lâchez-moi
avec la dépression,
elle a 16 ans.
- Ma plus vieille fille, la plus
grande, c'est l'inspiration
de son cheminement, de mon
cheminement, de notre relation
qui est vraiment amenée à
un autre niveau. On a pas eu
tous ces problèmes-là,
mais il y a des discussions,
là-dedans, qui se sont
retrouvées autour de la table
chez les Morissette à dire...
Bien voyons de quoi tu parles?
- T'as eu A dans ton examen
de sciences...
- Étant donné que la famille
parfaite n'existe pas,
le château de cartes finit
par s'écrouler dans "Le guide
de la famille parfaite".
Le réalisateur Ricardo Trogi
a dû y aller dans la nuance.
RICARDO TROGI, réalisateur
- Cette fois-ci j'ai poussé
un petit peu plus que d'habitude
l'aspect dramatique. En tout
cas... J'ai été moi-même une
victime du film. Dans la mesure
ou je suis un père de famille.
Avec une jeune fille, moi aussi,
à peu près de l'âge... fait que
j'étais plus sensible peut-être
au sujet...
- Une soirée de bonheur
et de temps de qualité...
- Une des belles phrases du film
est la suivante, et je cite :
"C'est lorsque tu as des enfants
que tu commences à avoir peur".
Une phrase qui a interpellé
une mère dans le film
et dans la vraie vie.
GENEVIÈVE CHABOT, comédienne
- Je suis maman,nouvellement,
d'une petite fille de 5 mois.
Et donc, en revoyant le film
c'est sûr... j'ai pleuré ma vie.
Parce que..., avec ce qui se
passe, c'est sûr que bon...
je veux pas révéler de punch,
mais, oui, les valves se sont
ouvertes, je me suis identifiée
dans mon rôle de mère, c'est
dûr, ça peut-être difficile être
une maman.
- Des fois moi aussi je trouve
ça "too much", mais tout
le monde le fait.
- Même si le rôle de parent
n'est pas de tout repos, Louis
Morissette ne l'échangerait
pour rien au monde.
- Oui c'est des soucis,
en même temps c'est
une grande chance d'avoir
des enfants, ça fait de moi
une bien meilleure personne.
- C'est pas parce que toi
tu as reçu des claques
qu'il faut faire pareil.
- "Le guide de la famille
parfaite" prendra l'affiche
le 14 juillet.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- À côté de ce que j'ai connu,
une petite claque en arrière
de la tête, je te faisais
une faveur jeune homme.
- Laisse faire tes grands
conseils d'éducation... Les ados